shop has resigned it follows an
investigation into his part in
facilitating an 800 000 pound loan
guarantee to the former prime minister
Boris Johnson the publication of that
report is expected imminently Mr Sharp
made this statement a few moments ago
good morning I would like to thank Adam
heppenstahl and his team for the
diligence and professionalism they have
shown in compiling today's report
Mr happenstall's View is that while I
did breach the governance code for
public appointments he States very
clearly that a breach does not
necessarily invalidate an appointment
indeed I've always maintained the breach
was inadvertent and not Material which
the facts he lays out substantiate
the secretary of state has consulted
with the BBC board who support that view
nevertheless I have decided that it is
right to prioritize the interests of the
BBC
I feel that this matter May well be a
distraction from the corporation's good
work were I to remain in post until the
end of my term
I have therefore this morning
resigned as a BBC chair to the Secretary
of State and to the board
it was proposed to me that I stay on his
chair until the end of June while the
process to a point my successor is
undertaken and I will of course do that
in the interests of the corporation's
stability and continuity
let me turn to the events that a subject
of today's report
when I sought in December 2020 to
introduce the cabinet secretary to Mr
Blythe I did so in good faith
I did so with the best of intentions
and I did so with the sole purpose of
ensuring that all relevant rules were
being followed
I am pleased that Mr heppenstall
supports the fact
that my involvement in these matters as
he States was accordingly very limited
after extensive work he States his words
that he's happy to record that he seen
no evidence and nor could he to say I
played any part whatsoever in
facilitation
arrangement
or financing of a loan to the former
prime minister
now during my conversation
with the cabinet secretary on December
the 4th 2020.
I reminded him of the fact that I was in
the BBC appointment process
I believed as a result of that
conversation that I had been removed
from any conflict or perception of
conflict
I understood this recusal
to be absolute
this was my error
in my subsequent interview with the
appointments panel I wish
with the benefit of hindsight this
potential perceived conflict of interest
was something I'd considered to mention
I would like once again to apologize
that oversight inadvertent third was and
for the distraction these events have
caused the BBC
for more than 20 years I've devoted time
and energy to Public Service whether the
Institute of cancer research at the
Royal Academy of Arts
on the financial policy policy Committee
of the bank of England or as an economic
advisor to the treasury working up to
protect British business including the
creative Industries during the pandemic
and for more than two years now I've
seen the Beating Heart of the BBC up
close
and for all its complexities successes
and occasional failings the BBC is an
incredible Dynamic and well-beating
creative Force unmatched anywhere
as chair I have acted at all times in
the public interest and for the
betterment of the BBC
I'm proud to have fought for the recent
return
of government funding for the World
Service I've been active in
commissioning independent thematic
reviews of BBC coverage on touchdown
issues and I've championed the
importance of the BBC as a well-funded
and impartial public service broadcaster
to chair this incredible organization
has been an honor the BBC's contribution
to our national life is immense its
people are hard-working and absolutely
brilliant and preserving and enhancing
it really matters thank you
so that was a statement from Richard
Sharp the outgoing chairman of the BBC
he has resigned in the last few minutes
that follows an investigation by Adam
hepp install Casey that suggested that
he potentially breached the regulations
regarding his appointment as chairman of
the BBC because of his facilitation of a
loan guarantee to the former prime
minister Boris Johnson we can go now to
Westminster our political correspondent
Joe Pike is there Joe the report has
just been published I mean the key point
that Richard short was emphasizing there
is that this was a potential breach
rather than an actual breach
but nonetheless uh Ian it was a breach
of the code and Adam happenedstall
making it clear that uh that Richard
Sharp should have mentioned that uh
conflict of interest he should have
mentioned it in his report and towards
the bottom uh Miss eppen style writes Mr
Sharp should have made the disclosure
set out in this key findings section
ultimately the BBC chairman has jumped
before I think pressure built which
would have led to him ultimately being
pushed there were two ways out of this
one he could have resigned the procedure
for removing a BBC chair involved the
Secretary of State for culture
Consulting with a BBC board ultimate I
suppose Richard sunac might have been
the the decision maker uh telling his
his uh Secretary of State what to do
that would have been ugly you know we're
likely to get a reaction in the in the
coming minutes to that report from the
labor party from opposition parties and
from uh MPS on the culture select
committee remember that selectment has
already been incredibly critical of Mr
Sharp saying that he breached the stand
as expected that this was a significant
error of judgment therefore I think it's
was the recognition of Mr Sharp that it
would have been too difficult to stay on
and as he said in that statement it
would have really damaged the BBC's
reputation which already has been
battered by a number of uh rails
including the Gary linear Corral but
this has been uh swirling around for a
number of months and clearly is not good
for the corporation ultimately the fact
that Richard Sharp didn't tell either
the culture committee when he gave
evidence or the appointment panel when
applying for the job about his role in
facilitating that this loan did for him
now he he argues as as he explained in
that statement that Mr happenstall
agrees he didn't play a key role in any
role in facilitating arranging or
financing the loan to Boris Johnson and
allies of Mr Sharp I've spoken to have
said that
um it is it is agreed that he he did not
know until it appeared later in he was
asked about this by journalists that
there would be a loan or loan guarantee
but of course he did have contact with
Sam Blyth then went to the cabinet
secretary at Simon case that was Miss
tappenstar argues a conflict of interest
he should have mentioned when applying
for this very senior a high-paid job on
a pretty high salary 160 a thousand
pounds a year and therefore uh he has
decided to go now Ian what happens next
well he's gonna uh stand uh reign in
position until a replacement is found so
he's going to be in position for a few
more months but clearly a very
embarrassing episode for uh Mr Sharp
also I think perhaps his decision today
saves Richie sunac from having to make a
difficult decision we know the prime
minister is appearing later today in
Scotland and Wales at party conferences
Conservative Party Conference the Welsh
conservatives a Party Conference likely
I'm sure to be asked about this but the
fact that Mr Sharp has acted and acted
fast at doing that statement recording
that statement with the BBC even before
the report was released to all of this I
think was has saved Rishi sunak uh some
difficult uh difficult questions and he
argues Mr Sharp argues it saves also the
BBC for a more difficult uh painful
headlines he said that what he did was
with the best of intentions he claims
there's no evidence he played any part
in a facilitation Arrangement or
financing of that loan to Boris Johnson
but also there was regret there he
regretted as he said that he hadn't
mentioned this to the two to the panel
and to the culture select committee he
apologized to BBC staff for the
distraction he has been in recent weeks
and now his time as BBC chair is coming
to an end he's acted uh quickly in but I
suppose critics of Mr Sharp would argue
he should have acted many months ago
this report has dragged the story out
unnecessarily long and therefore he has
caused yet more damage to the
organization the corporation that he
should have been standing up for and
prioritizing in his job as chairman Joe
what really strikes me as being very
interesting in all of this uh looking
again at the statement from Richard
Sharp announcing his resignation a few
moments ago is that he stresses that
Adam happened still uh found that his
breach was inadvertent and not material
and actually the BBC board appears to
have come to that conclusion so it
sounds very much so Richard Sharp
retained the backing of the BBC board
certainly allies in Avista chart for
said in recent days that there are
people on the BBC board who are very
supportive of his of his contribution
on that fact of a breach of the
appointments code
it is clear and Mr Sharp recognized even
before this report was out that he had
breached uh the code
um and as you say the sort of Judgment
of Mr happenstall was was how bad was
that breach was it material breach was
it an inadvertent breach of course
um Mr Sharp argued it and has argued
that it was inadvertent he clearly does
have some supporters on the BBC board
and there are certain media reports
today that that senior BBC management
some senior BBC management are publicly
very supportive of the role he has
played of course what the BBC have now
with Mr Sharp is somebody who is pretty
supportive of uh their their needing
more funding but also can communicate
with Rishi sunak well because he used to
work from a Goldman Sachs he he is some
people within the BBC argue an effective
a communicator effective lobbyist
towards uh Mr Suna But ultimately the
bad headlines Ian he has created in
recent weeks hanging on to his job as
Miss heppenstar has been compiling this
report has been damaging to the
corporation and that I think is
ultimately why he's decided that if he
hadn't resigned now and he'd have
created even even worse headlines and
that would have been yeah damaging to
the BBC for a number of days potentially
and therefore he's therefore he's
decided to jump before he potentially
was pushed
okay thanks uh Joe for that uh well
joining me now on the telephone is
Professor Tim lockhurst he's principal
of Durham University's South College and
he is of course a former editor of news
programs at BBC Scotland uh Tim
lockhurst your reaction please
well the BBC
service chairman who was probably more
friendly to the BC than many other
conservatives the circumstances in which
Richard Sharp has resigned are of course
ones which for which he is responsible
and he's taking responsibility for his
error and quit at this stage but I think
the BBC now faces a challenge as he
recognize Richard Sharp is regarded
inside the BBC as a very competent and
supportive chairman and given any
conservative government is going to
appoint a conservative to chair the BBC
the BEC will be wondering where they're
going to get somebody who is as
competent and supportive and as
passionate about the BBC as Richard
Sharp clearly has been
Tim I'm I'm struck by I mean the people
say that uh history doesn't uh repeat
itself but it often Rhymes I mean of
course the BBC was in this position 19
years ago when another former chairman
who was also an ex-goldman Sachs
executive Gavin Davis uh resigned over
the BBC's coverage of the Iraq War I
mean what sort of uh what is this going
to do for morale inside the BBC
that'll be a major challenge for BBC
management and I'm sure that they're
conscious of it as you say they have had
previous experience and such
resignations and a such controversy it's
important to note of course the chairman
isn't a Hands-On editorial figure rather
a supporter guide and advisor to Sydney
a BBC Executives and in that sense they
will be in a good position to move
forward but staff do need reassurance
the BBC's rarely been under as much
pressure as it currently is under and in
the sense that he was a conservative who
understood as the purpose of license fee
understood the value of the BBC as a
public service broadcaster I know that
there will be anxiety amongst BBC staff
about what happens in future and about
whether they could really expect to get
someone with a similar set of sympathies
to replace Richard Sharp as their
chairman well I think that's a really
really good point you've made that I
mean uh in terms of someone who could
fight the BBC's Corner particularly here
with all sorts of questions over the
BBC's funding you couldn't really have
got someone better than Richard Sharp
you know who knows the highways and
byways of the finance sector really well
and as you say you know Richie sunac
used to work for him that's absolutely
right and of course to get someone in
politics who is well connected in the
conservative party and also synthetic to
the corporation is a very big challenge
after all there are not many in politics
and certainly few in the conservative
party who are really familiar with the
broadcast sector and who really have
sympathy for the public sector
broadcasting ideals he's not the only
one there are others but many of them
are people who are currently doing
rather serious jobs and working
full-time in other positions so this is
going to be a big Challenge and it will
be very interesting to see how quickly
the government goes about replacing Mr
Sharp because it is after all the prime
ministerial decision and how carefully
they do it and will they privilege the
interest of the conservative party or
seek to balance the interest the
conservative party with the interest of
the BBC at a time when a general
election is looming that's a crucial
question
of course greatly appreciate you joining
me this morning thank you very much
indeed uh this story obviously uh
developing uh by the minute the BBC
board has just issued the following
statement let me read that to you the
BBC board statement says we accept and
understand Richard's decision to stand
down we want to put on record our thanks
to Richard who has been a valued and
respected colleague and a very effective
chairman of the BBC the BBC board
believes that Richard Sharp is a person
of Integrity Richard has been a real
advocate for the BBC its Mission and why
the corporation is a Priceless asset for
the country at home and abroad he has
always had the impartiality of the BBC
and a desire to see the organization
Thrive at the Forefront of his work as
chairman we understand that the UK
government is moving swiftly to begin
the process of appointing a new chairman
of the BBC in line with the terms of the
BBC's Charter
so there you go very interesting uh
indeed though I mean that really
reiterates what I was saying to Joe Pike
a couple of moments ago which was that
the BBC board was clearly behind its
chairman but he's obviously decided for
uh reasons of uh of maintaining uh
keeping the focus off the BBC he has
decided to go we'll uh we can get
further reaction now uh from Ali
Fortescue who is in Westminster now Ali
you've been having a look at the
reporter from Adam heptin still what's
uh what's in it
yeah well we know um that Richard Sharp
has decided to go but we are still
looking through the detail this is a
report it's just landed it's about 25
pages long
um and if I take you to the second page
here you go he says um the successful
candidate Mr Richard Sharp failed to
disclose a potential perceived conflict
of interest to the panel so that is
right at the heart of this
um this was what this was looking at
that loan guarantee
um between the Richard Sharp Health the
former prime minister Boris Johnson
um get and you see here Mr Sharp
informed uh the Prime Minister that he
wished to be chair of the BBC board that
is crucial not something I'm sure that
we knew before and then it goes on to
say you can see at the bottom 2.3 these
matters gave rise to a potential
perceived conflict of interest there is
a risk of a perception that Mr Sharp was
recommended for appointment because he
assisted the former prime minister in a
private Financial matter and or he
influenced the former prime minister to
recommend him by informing him of his
application before he submitted it there
may well have been a risk for a
perception that Mr Sharp would not be
independent from the former prime
minister so that goes right to the heart
of this a breach of the governance code
there you go in the report by Adam
heppingstall Casey a brute of the
government's code does not invalidate an
appointment he goes on to say and this
is what Richard Sharp was mentioning in
that statement you heard from him there
he was Keen to say that he didn't
necessarily have to go because a
governance code does not invalidate an
appointment but because there is a
breach of the governance code and I
think the sense you get is that the BBC
chairman does not want to be someone who
is in the headlines he obviously is all
about keeping the impartiality the
perceived and partiality of the BBC so
he clearly felt it was time to go that
is a big news this morning but we're
obviously getting into the detail this
25-page report that has just landed Ian
and here you clearly see
um the former prime minister in a
private Financial matter and all that he
influenced former prime minister to
recommend him by informing him of his
application before he submitted it that
is absolutely crucial to this
all right thanks Sally
still getting reaction uh right now just
to update you the chairman of the BBC
Richard Sharp has resigned during the
last 15 minutes this follows the
publication of a report by Adam hepp
install QC into Casey into his
involvement in the facilitation of a
loan guarantee to the former prime
minister Boris Johnson which was not
disclosed at the time that he was going
through the appointment process to
become chairman of the BBC uh we've got
a letter that I can read you now from
the culture secretary Lucy Fraser this
is to Richard Sharp and uh the letter
says thank you for your letter notify me
of your decision to resign from your
position as chair of the British
Broadcasting Corporation I understand
and respect your decision to stand down
as you have stated the BBC is a great
National Institution over the past 100
years it has touched the lives of almost
everyone in the United Kingdom and plays
a unique part in our cultural heritage
it is respected globally reaching
hundreds of millions of people across
the world every week no other country in
the world has anything quite like it I
would like to take this opportunity to
thank you for the work that you have
done and the leadership you have
provided as chair of the BBC you have
been a champion for what a strong BBC
can achieve not only for audiences at
home but also for the BBC's contribution
to the economy and to the UK's Global
Soft power I would like to express my
gratitude for the work with that you'll
work with the government to maintain the
BBC World Service in its unrivaled
status as the world's largest
International broadcaster and supporting
its crucial role in tackling harmful
disinformation through providing trusted
news and Analysis globally I know that
you are held in high regard by the BBC
board you have clearly demonstrated your
commitment to public service and I
especially applaud the work that you did
during the pandemic your decision to
step down in the wider interests of the
corporation is further Testament to that
commitment certainty and stability for
the corporation are clearly a shared
priority in this context I have spoken
into the board and they have proposed
that you stay in place until the next
board meeting on the 27th of June 2023
whilst an acting chair is appointed in
line with the charter I have accepted
this and would like to thank you for
your continued service to assist in
ensuring an orderly and smooth
transition takes place we will also move
to launch a process to identify and
appoint a permanent new chair thank you
once again for your service and I wish
you well for the future I am sure there
will be further opportunities for you to
make a significant contribution to
public life that is the culture
secretary Lucy Fraser a letter there to
the outgoing chair of the BBC Richard
Sharp has resigned in the last 20
minutes so we can go back to Joe Pike in
Westminster there I mean Joe this
narrative is really really uh taking
shape now that uh Richard shop has acted
with Integrity that he didn't
intentionally do anything wrong and had
the full backing of the BBC board
interesting Ian that Lucy Fraser says
she respects his decision as well and
that letter that you've just read out of
course she partly respects the decision
because it makes her life uh far easier
the charter states that she would have
had a role in uh firing him ultimately
would be up to her in consultation with
the uh BBC board and uh ultimately for
Rishi Suna would have been the key
decision maker here by by jumping by
deciding to resign Mr Sharp has made
life for both the culture and the Prime
Minister easier yes there are people
who've been supportive of Mr Sharp As
you say there are many people within the
BBC BBC board who have been supportive I
suppose it was always there was always a
sort of balance to be struck here
between the ongoing damage of Mr Sharp
remaining in that job the continuing bad
headlines that he provoked yes he
breached the code maybe it wasn't a
material breach but he was involved in
some way in this alone being given to
Boris Johnson by a rich financier now
maybe he wasn't directly involved in it
but certainly the fact he went to the
cabinet secretary Simon case to warn him
about it and to warn him that he wanted
to apply for the job as BBC chairman I
think it shows that there was a conflict
a conflict that Mr Sharp recognized that
he should have mentioned both to the
appointments panel and to the culture
select committee that select committee
have already reported saying that there
was a breach of the stand as expected
and Mr Sharp made a significant error of
judgment a more reaction from
politicians in the last few minutes Lucy
Powell he's a shadow culture secretary
has tweeted this I have this morning
received the report of the investigation
to Richard Sharp which labor instigated
the report is clear Mr Sharp breached
the rules expected of candidates by
failing to disclose his involvement in a
personal loan to the then PM as a result
this breach has caused Untold damage to
the reputation of the BBC and seriously
undermined its independence as a result
of the conservatives sleaze and cronyism
this comes after 13 years of the Tories
doing everything they can to defend
themselves and their mates from Owen
Patterson to Dominic raabtree says an
average a shot instead of doing what's
best for the country the PM was more
interested in defending his old banking
boss the PM should have sacked him weeks
ago and said it took this investigation
called by labor to make him resign
obviously Lucy Powell with a pretty
political Punchy responses to the
um a different tone struck by the the
culture secretary she ends Lucy Powell
by saying Rishi sunak should urgently
establish a truly independent and robust
process to replace sharp to help restore
some trust in the BBC after his
government has tarnished it so badly now
of course Miss sharp was a conservative
Zone isn't a conservative donor but they
have caught of course been under labor
Prime Ministers labor appointees to this
key position it's always been a
political a position that of BBC uh
chairman and therefore a son would argue
that labor need to remember that when
they are criticizing what has happened
uh here I'm sure we'll have a more
reaction in in the uh in the coming
hours but it does seem pretty clear that
Mr Sharp realizes the continuing
damaging impact if you were to remain in
post and what could have happened today
after the happenstyle report had
appeared if you hadn't resigned was more
people more politicians more members of
the culture select committee are asking
for him to resign we could have had
difficult TV moments with him him being
you know doorstep he has managed to
neutralize all of that this was I
suppose a decision about his future but
also as a carefully a thought out
communication strategy to sort of kill
that story before it blew up he's
decided to resign but we know he'll stay
for two more months in that position
until an acting chair of the BBC board
is appointed
thanks Joe well joining me now is Alex
Crowley he's worked closely with Boris
Johnson including on his conservative
leadership campaign but he quit as a
Downing Street political advisor in
September 2019. Alex thanks for joining
me this morning I mean I'm I'm reminded
in all of this I mean this whole Saga
unraveled began when the Sunday Times uh
reported in January of uh Richard Shop's
involvement in facilitating this loan
guarantee the background to all this of
course was that around the time the loan
was arranged Boris Johnson was in
serious financial difficulties
uh yes and I think Richard Sharp has
been somewhat the victim of uh boris's
uh shall we say chaotic uh uh personal
life which he perhaps didn't ever
imagine uh that it would lead to this I
think it's worth remembering that we use
the language about facilitation of a
loan and arranging alone of course it
makes him sound like he's a sort of bank
manager when I think in reality as as I
think the report today makes clear is
that he set up a meeting uh to have a
discussion about this and whilst it's
entirely right that
um there was a technical breach of the
rules he should have declared it to the
panel who was making this decision he
did not declare it and therefore it's a
breach and and you know fair enough he's
done the right thing and resigned
um we're not talking about some Grand
conspiracy here I think
now it's quite interesting I've just
been rereading the original Sunday Times
report on this uh from January this year
I mean it did have some extraordinary
details in it uh saying that uh Sam
Blythe who was the uh the provider of
the the loan guarantee so before the
loan was finalized Johnson sharp and
Blyth had a private dinner at Checkers
the prime minister's grace and favor
home in the Chilton Hills in
buckinghamshire where according to a
source they at Chop Suey and drank wine
I mean it's it's an extraordinary way
for a sitting prime minister to get to
go about business isn't it
uh yes yeah look it's a very unorthodox
way clearly of of going about things and
and look we we don't none of us knows
the true state of of Boris Johnson's
personal finances we know what clearly
he declares as he has to as an MP and
what he had to as a prime minister but
yes look it was a very unusual State of
Affairs um but you know he is a very
unusual politician in that regard and
ultimately his own kind of chaotic style
of doing things and not quite doing
things properly ultimately led to his
downfall
um and so he has paid the price for that
and now it appears of course lots of
other people are are paying the price
for that too including today Richard
Sharp absolutely what do you think the
characteristics of the next chair of the
BBC are going to likely to have to be I
mean it's a I mean Richard Sharp was in
many ways the ideal chair of the BBC he
was well plugged into conservative
circles Rishi sunak had worked for him
he's an extremely experienced financier
uh just about everything that the BBC
really needs as it juggles with these uh
great funding commitments and challenges
it faces
yes look it's important to remember that
this is a political appointment
um I don't think we should take any
lessons from the labor party who are
saying Oh No it should be completely
apolitical it should be completely
straight down the line it isn't a
political labor governments have
appointed labor people to this role just
as conservative governments have done
likewise the key test here is is it
someone who actually has the gravitas
and the authority it's not did they
donate to the conservative party do they
vote conservative do they vote labor is
are they right for the role and it's not
unreasonable for the prime minister of
the day to appoint someone
um that is at least vaguely politically
aligned to them once you become BBC
chairman of course you have to follow
the rules of the BBC and of course as
we've seen with Richard Sharp today
there is Big public school and
accountability for that role but there
is politics behind all of this the
reason why that people went after
Richard Sharp is because they didn't
like the fact that that Boris had
appointed someone who was linked to the
conservative party we saw it with the
attempt to appoint Paul daker as well
there's lots of politics around me so
the next appointment uh you know we
should soon act should do it with
confidence pick someone he believes in
uh and obviously follow the right
process
all right Alex Rowley good to talk to
you this morning appreciate you joining
me thank you I'm just going to remind
you of the news that's broken during the
last half hour which is that Richard
Sharp the chairman of the BBC has
resigned this follows a report by the
king's Council Adam hepinstall into the
circumstances in which Boris Johnson
received a loan guarantee in which uh
Richard shop was said to have been
involved that was not disclosed during
the process to which he was appointed to
the BBC the report says that uh the
breach of any rules was inadvertent and
not deliberate but Richard shop has
nonetheless decided to resign we can
read you we can play now what Richard
Sharp said just a few moments ago
good morning I would like to thank Adam
heppenstahl and his team for the
diligence and professionalism they have
shown in compiling today's report
Mr happenstall's View
is that while I did breach the
governance code for public appointments
he States very clearly that a breach
does not necessarily invalidate an
appointment
indeed I've always maintained the breach
was inadvertent and not Material which
the facts he lays out substantiate
the secretary of state has consulted
with the BBC board who support that view
nevertheless I have decided that it is
right to prioritize the interests of the
BBC
I feel that this matter May well be a
distraction from the corporation's good
work were I to remain in post until the
end of my term
I have therefore this morning
resigned as a BBC chair to the Secretary
of State and to the board
it was proposed to me that I stay on his
chair until the end of June while the
process to a point my successor is
undertaken and I will of course do that
in the interests of the corporation's
stability and continuity
let me turn to the events that a subject
of today's report
when I sought in December 2020 to
introduce the cabinet secretary to Mr
Blythe I did so in good faith
I did so with the best of intentions
and I did so with the sole purpose of
ensuring that all relevant rules were
being followed
I am pleased that Mr happenstall
supports the fact
that my involvement in these matters as
he States was accordingly very limited
after extensive work he States his words
that he's happy to record that has seen
no evidence and nor could he to say I
played any part whatsoever in
facilitation
arrangement
or financing of a loan to the former
prime minister
now during my conversation
with the cabinet secretary on December
the 4th 2020
I reminded him of the fact that I was in
the BBC appointment process
I believed as a result of that
conversation that I had been removed
from any conflict or perception of
conflict
I understood this recusal
to be absolute
this was my error
in my subsequent interview with the
appointments panel I wish
with the benefit of hindsight this
potential perceived conflict of interest
was something I'd consider to mention
I would like once again to apologize
that oversight inadvertent third was and
for the distraction these events have
caused the BBC
for more than 20 years I've devoted time
and energy to Public Service whether the
Institute of cancer research at the
Royal Academy of Arts
on the financial policy policy Committee
of the bank of England or as an economic
advisor to the treasury working up to
protect British business including the
creative Industries during the pandemic
and for more than two years now I've
seen the Beating Heart of the BBC up
close
and for all its complexities successes
and occasional failings the BBC is an
incredible Dynamic and well-beating
creative Force unmatched anywhere
as chair I have acted at all times in
the public interest and for the
betterment of the BBC
I'm proud to have fought for the recent
return
of government funding for the World
Service I've been active in
commissioning independent thematic
reviews of BBC coverage on touchdown
issues and I've championed the
importance of the BBC as a well-funded
and impartial public service broadcaster
to chair this incredible organization
has been an honor the BBC's contribution
to our national life is immense its
people are hard-working and absolutely
brilliant and preserving and enhancing
it really matters thank you
so that was Richard Sharp's resignation
statement uh in the last half hour
they're resigning over the publication
of reports that suggested he
inadvertently breached rules during the
appointment process to his becoming the
chairman of the BBC that report of
course by Adam hepp install QC Casey Ali
fortescu's been looking at that report
while we've been on air Ali here
anything uh else struck you in the last
few minutes
yeah so we've got the report 25 pages
long
um we'd be going through it you can see
we've got a new little bit here
obviously this is all about
um what did Richard Sharp tell to the
panel that was interviewing him when he
was going for the job of BBC chairman um
here we go it may well have been a
reasonable conversation in the context
of Mr Sharp's role as special advisor
but failing to mention it to the panel
does amount to a failure to disclose a
potential perceived conflict of interest
so there's a potential perceived
conflict of interest obviously that is
right at the heart of this this is all
about the loan guarantee that Richard
Sharp helped Boris Johnson where he goes
on to say whilst it might have been
appropriate for Mr Sharp to inform his
boss of his application particularly in
light of Mr Sharp's work at the at a
time of national emergency it was also
appropriate for him to have informed the
panel of the conversation so Richard
Sharp should have told the panel that
was interviewing him about out this
conversation that he'd had about this
loan guarantee that he'd helped Boris
Johnson with we do know that he told the
cabinet secretary but if we go back a
few pages here we go and this is all
about how number 10 was helping
um push really for Richard Sharp to get
the job at the time we know the job of
BBC chairman is something that the Prime
Minister has a say in number 10
commented to dcms culture media and
Sport department on the 26th of November
2020 that Mr Sharp looked like a strong
candidate and it goes on to say number
10 support for Richard Sharp was made
known to the panel that he was the only
candidate identified to the panel as
having his candidacy supported by
ministers so there you go a perceived
conflict of interest we know now that
Richard Sharp has stepped down as
traveling to the BBC and we will of
course course keep looking through the
fine print in this document and let you
know if we find anything more
interesting Ian all right thanks Sally
uh we can go back to uh Joe Pike in
Westminster as well I mean Joe uh give
me some thoughts on uh how Rishi sunak
emerges from all of this because uh this
report came out first of all in the
Sunday Times in late January by
mid-February a lot of media Grande's the
likes of Jonathan dimbleby former BBC
presenter Chris Patton a former chairman
of the BBC of course all of them
indicating that they felt that Richard
Sharp should stand down and throughout
that process Rishi sunak said nope we
must wait for the independent uh report
from Adam hepp install to uh give his
conclusions does Richie sunak in any way
emerge slightly weaker from having uh
sort of waited for process to take its
course here
it's a really interesting question Ian
certainly the Prime Minister has tried
to keep far away from the TV cameras on
this topic and out of the headlines a
bit like this time last week when we
were talking about Dominic Raab
resigning we didn't see Rishi sunath on
camera for quite some time clearly
wanting to keep away from the front line
when a bad headlines hit although he
will be at the conservative Scottish
conservative conference in Scotland
today and in Wales for the Welsh
conservative conference so we may hear a
little bit more from him yes I suppose
this is partly damaging because we know
that
um Mr sharp is a is a friend of a Rishi
a former boss a former colleague at
Goldman Sachs ultimately though Rishi
sunak faces uh this sort of small crisis
I suppose you could call it bad
headlines because of one of his
predecessors yeah yet again uh Boris
Johnson and in this case his finances is
causing problems for Rishi now of course
Boris Johnson's attitudes towards
standards has has caused caused trouble
with the standards committee
investigation privileges committee
investigation into what Boris Johnson
told Parliament that is something very
difficult for British unac to deal with
this is something
um similar I suppose because if Boris
Johnson hadn't been in such a difficult
financial position Sam Blythe wouldn't
have seen that in the newspapers wanted
to do something approach Richard Sharp
which led to this a whole thing kicking
off there are still questions about who
was providing financial support to Boris
Johnson while he was prime minister
certainly a lack of clarity there but I
don't think we're going to get much more
clarity on it certainly allies of that
former prime minister saying it's not in
the public interest for there to be any
more uh transparency on that meanwhile
one big question is what does happen
with the appointment process certainly
labor haven't yet called for this to be
a non-political appointment to be handed
completely independently but we do know
they've appointed an independent BBC
review panel to look into all of this
and look at that issue so it's possible
when that reports labor policy could
change and therefore if they're in a
government in 18 months time or so we
could see that change I think it's
perhaps unlikely to change before the
acting chair is is appointed in two
months time and therefore before the
appointment process for a permanent BBC
chair kicks off certainly I think
there'll be a huge amount of media
interest in that actually in the report
Mr heppandole seems critical of the fact
that so much of that process seems to
have been played in the public sphere
um saying this leaks and briefing to the
Press of preferred candidates
should be prohibited by ministers if
this does happen then mitigating steps
should be considered also interesting on
that point that Mr Sharp says uh his
breach of the rules was inadvertent that
was a key sort of message in that
statement he delivered at the BBC today
were worth noting that the KC Mr
ebensall doesn't
um
comment on that he says Mr shop has
stated to me that if there was a failure
to disclose a conflict it was
inadvertent as noted elsewhere in this
report it's not for me to form a
judgment on Mr Sharp's conduct so this
happened so not not agreeing or
disagreeing with that even though that
is a key sort of communication line for
the now uh outgoing BBC chairman yes I
think Ian this could be more more
damaging for Richardson if Mr Sharp
hadn't resigned but by acting and acting
quickly even before the report was
published I think he's probably saved
his former Goldman Sachs colleague from
a particularly difficult day in front of
the TV cameras in Scotland and Wales
yeah Joe is this an opportunity perhaps
for Rishi sunak to try and depoliticize
the role of BBC chairman as Alex Crowley
was saying to me earlier on uh this
morning this has always been a political
role labor governments appointed people
like Michael Lyons and uh Gavin Davis
both of whom were labor supporters to
the role of chairman the conservatives
have likewise done similarly with Chris
Patton and now obviously with uh Richard
shop is this an opportunity for what to
want someone for all de-politicize this
as labor seem to be suggesting
it is it is an opportunity but there are
those who argue within government that
the BBC has a very big funding
settlement via the license repairs and
it is completely
um reasonable that the government of the
day democratically elected government
does have some sort of oversight of that
through this role now the role of of BBC
uh chairman isn't a sort of a day-to-day
management role ultimately Tim Davey and
his team to be the director General and
his team uh are managing the corporation
day to day and some would argue this is
this sort of oversight role with some
sort of government link is completely
Fair especially since it's a license fee
pairs who are funding uh the corporation
and and the government is is
democratically elected by them but I
think the fact there have been so many
bad headlines in the last three months
over Richard Sharp's links to the
conservative is a donor but also as
somebody who played some even small role
in uh trying to sort out Boris Johnson's
finances you know that doesn't look good
and you could completely see in in the
future another political appointment uh
causing causing causing similar problems
I think what it means even if there
isn't a deep politicization of this role
what it means is that is that the
appointment process for the next person
has got to be incredibly rigorous
it's going to be a tough process both
the appointments panel and the evidence
that the sort of final nominee will give
to the culture select committee that may
indeed put off some potential applicants
if it looks like such a a sort of uh a
poison chalice if it looks too difficult
it may potentially put off some really
uh talented applicants but now the
search is underway for an acting chair
they'll take over on the 27th of June
and the process will begin to appoint a
new uh a person to this role of BBC
chairman and it is it is well paid Ian
160 000 pounds a year
okay thanks Joe uh joining me now is the
conservative pair Lord Moylan the former
advisor to Boris Johnson Lord and
welcome to you I mean the the consensus
seems to be emerging that actually
Richard Sharp whatever he did wrong was
inadvertence he's he's acted with
Integrity by going in the way that he
has done isn't this just really evidence
that anyone you know who comes into
Boris Johnson ultimately their
reputation gets contaminated
my reputation hasn't been contaminated
I'll give you a list of uh at least a
hundred people who've worked with um
Boris Johnson whose reputation I know
from personal knowledge hasn't been
contaminated
um I think that's a Preposterous thing
to say uh that this was a small
administrative error I think Mr Sharp
whom I don't know uh and and of course I
haven't read the report in full because
it's only just been published so with
those caveats uh Mr Sharp appears to
have uh disclosed what might be a
conflict of interest to the cabinet
secretary and thought that he was
fulfilling the rules by doing that it's
been found that he didn't fulfill the
rules by doing that that wasn't quite
enough and and very honorably I think
we've all agreed he stood down
um as a result of being found to have
made that modest breach I don't actually
see how this engages Boris Johnson at
all actually
well it does because Boris Johnson it
was his financial difficulties and the
fact that he needed to go back in
history you could say well what was the
interest the the question that's issue
here was did Mr Sharp have an interest
that he should have declared to the
panel it doesn't matter what the history
of that interest was and what he's been
found out
um what it's been said of him is that he
should have declared it he thought he'd
done that effectively but all right
model model
um and nobody thinks he was being
dishonest at all
um he thought he had declared it doesn't
matter what it was it could have been
his grandmother's interest in azaleas if
it was relevant to the job I don't see
what it really why there's any need to
bring Boris Johnson into this at all
because Boris Johnson in late 2020
needed a loan of 800 000 pounds I mean
that's not Richard Sharp's fault
well
all right as I say you can go into the
history of what led to the conflict of
interest that's not about what today's
report is about what today's report
about is did he have a conflict of
interest which he should have declared
and it was found that he didn't and he's
behaved very responsibly in going
although uh that is he didn't declare it
although he thought he had and and
that's really as far as I can tell is
the is the long and the short of this
whole uh quite expensive report
um so there was a conflict of interest
and it was to do with Boris the idea
that everybody's reputation you know
who's connected with Boris is destroyed
um is complete nonsense or this isn't
even really a story about Boris there
are stories there are things you might
want to ask about Boris and finances I
don't know the answers to them they've
got nothing to do with Richard Sharp or
the BBC
apologies for any uh imputation on that
suggested that your reputation was
tarnished
and you seem to be suggesting straight
off that my reputation had been
tarnished why would why would you have
me on your show if I had such a bad
reputation no absolutely no we're not
implying uh there's been any damage but
it but it is a fat and nonetheless that
a lot of people who do come into Boris
Johnson into contact with him their
reputation ends up being damaged in some
way and Richard Sharp is really the
latest example of that well maybe that's
because the there are people in Britain
who want to eradicate Boris Johnson's
memory and they go for people near him
um very much as you have these attacks
on Trump at the moment to
um in America I'm not saying there's any
similarity between Trump and Boris
because five minutes intelligent
reflection shows that there isn't but
it's simply a technique that seems to be
growing particularly on the left is to
use quartz and smears and so on to keep
going at somebody even after they've
stood down
a little morning before I let you go I
mean this really does appear to be the
job from hell I mean you're in the
political Spotlight throughout uh who on
Earth would want this job who on Earth
would want to succeed Richard Sharp
I think it's a really really good
question and I don't think it's just BBC
jobs I think these high-profile
chairmanships where you get somebody who
has real business experience who doesn't
come from a political background who
isn't used to being abused on Twitter
the whole time and whatever but they
come out of a a world of business and
finance experience and they have a lot
to give
in these roles
and then they discover the sort of
battering they get and the publicity
they've been subjected to not just
Richard Sharp I think of other people
there as the man who was chairing the
the environment agency at the time of
the uh flooding and the um uh in the
dump in the somerset levels
um whose reputation was totally trash
because he was on his Christmas holiday
who's a very senior and significant
engineer who'd taken that job I I think
it's really difficult to persuade people
to do it
um because of the potential for exposure
and having your whole family laughed at
and and having your reputation ridiculed
not because you've done a bad job but
because of some something related to a
headline you never dare take a holiday
because if something goes wrong and
you're photographed on a beach you're
sort of trashed
um so I think it really is difficult but
I think it's really important for the
BBC to have somebody as chairman who is
their friend in government and you know
people write about this as if the if a
conservative comes in anywhere into the
Ambit of the BBC Administration they're
there as a sort of Attila the Hun coming
to destroy it whereas nearly all of them
actually are are there to be the bbcs
they they turn out to be the BBC's
friend at the heart of government and if
you cut yourself off completely to into
a holy political sphere you won't have
any friends of part of government Lord
Moylan greatly appreciate you joining me
this morning thank you thank you very
much here this is the scene outside to
our new broadcasting house at the moment
we'll keep tabs on there what's going on
there but in the meantime back to Ali
Fortescue in Westminster Ali you've been
scouring the report from Adam pepinstall
over the last hour what more can you
tell us
hello yes right let's just get to some
of the best bits in this um or the most
interesting bits in this 25-page report
here you go
um
successful candidate Mr Richard Sharp
failed to disclose potential perceived
conflicts of interest to the panel that
goes right to the heart of this what did
Richard Sharp tell the panel for the
interview at the BBC board
um Mr Sharp informed the Prime Minister
he wished to apply for the chair of the
bbbc board that was one of the areas
where he went wrong and secondly Mr
Sharp also informed the former prime
minister he was going to meet with a
cabinet secretary to attempt to
introduce him to a person who might
assist him with his personal finances
this is all about that loan guarantee
that Richard Sharp helped Boris Johnson
with
um by setting him up with a distant
relative these matters gave rise he go
to a potential conflict of interest
there is a risk of a perception that Mr
Sharp was recommended for appointment
because he assisted the former prime
minister in a private Financial matter
and or that he influenced the former
prime minister to recommend him by
informing him of his application before
he submitted it
um so that there you go a breach of the
governance code you can see there that
is what it comes down to that is what
Richard Shaw mentioned in that interview
this morning
um he does go on to say though in this
report that a breach of the governance
code does not invalidate the appointment
that was saying that Richard Sharp
touched on as well
um in his interview but he has still
decided to go and I just want to show
you one more bit very quickly if we have
time
um here this is all about
the pressure really that number 10 was
putting on make giving Richard Sharp
that job of BBC chairman of course the
Prime Minister does play a role in that
it was very clear
um that after speaking to Boris Johnson
after helping him
um with that loan guaranteed he was a
preferred candidate number 10 commented
um to the Department of culture media
and Sport in November 2020 that Mr Sharp
looked like a strong candidate
goes on to say number 10 support for
Richard Sharp was made known to the
panel he was the only candidate
identified to the panel as having his
candidacy supported by ministers well
there you go after a long wait we have
this 25 five paid report making clear
um that Richard Shaw there was a
perceived conflict of interest Richard
Sharp did uh breach the rules we know
now obviously that he has decided to go
all right thanks very much for that ali
uh we can go back to Joe Pike in
Westminster our political correspondent
Joe uh any early Runners and Riders
being talked about
and not yet Ian but if you if you know
of any uh let me know we'll be uh
interested to talk to them because it
does sound like a bit of a difficult uh
process uh I'm sure it will be one with
a lot of media attention to replace uh
Richard Sharp there has been some more
political reaction uh well this this
time from Davey the leader of the
liberal Democrats both the lib Dems and
labor I think trying to use this moment
uh for their political Advantage perhaps
no surprise with local elections in
England just six days away this is what
uh Davey has said on Twitter the BBC is
being dragged through the mud by the
conservative party after yet another
sleaze Scandal everything these
conservative politicians touch turns
into a mess they're not fit to govern
our great country early we heard from
Lucy Palace had a culture secretary
who's been leading for labor on this
story saying that from Owen Patterson to
Dominic Raab and now Richard Sharp
instead of doing what's best for the
country the PM is more interested in
defending his old banking boss we should
point out
um that Richard was asked about Richard
Sharp when he visited San Diego by our
very own Sam coats and he didn't defend
Mr Sharp he didn't take the opportunity
to defend him so I'm not sure at least
past entirely right saying that Richard
has defended at his old banking boss but
she says the PM should have sacked him
weeks ago instead took this
investigation called by labor to make
him resign yes Rishi sunak is I suppose
a friend of Rich former government tax
colleague but he was appointed to BBC
chairman under the Premiership of Boris
Johnson and in fact this whole row as we
know Ian happened because of Boris
Johnson's finances or maybe rather the
lack of those uh of finances Mr Sharp
did breach the rules that happens to the
report is very clear about that yes that
doesn't invalidate his appointment he
could have tried to State although I
think it would have been a pretty
difficult situation there would have
been increasing calls for him to go a
yes Richard Sharp argues that breach of
the rules not uh not notifying both the
appointments panel and the culture
select committee about his role in this
loan that that was he says an
inadvertent breach the Casey in this
isn't commenting on that isn't agreeing
or disagreeing but I think perhaps it
was inevitable to Richard Sharp uh would
have to go considering there have been
three months of very uh bad headlines
bad damaging headlines for the
corporation it always was a balance it
was the leadership of the BBC Ball by Mr
Sharp so good so much better than a
potential successor that he should stay
over the sort of reputational damage to
the BBC every time a different uh
headline appeared and of course the
Sunday Times first reported this in late
January so it has been some quite some
time of bad bad headlines he is off he's
no longer the BBC chair
okay Joe thanks for that just a reminder
of what's happened during the last hour
Richard Sharp has resigned as chairman
of the BBC I'm back on Tuesday with the
business news in the meantime on my
interview with Alison Rose from NatWest
will be on our digital platform soon see
you Tuesday cheerio
[Music]